- So I'm a mom of
(crowd applauses)
two wonderful girls.
Maybe I'm a little biased.
But listen, it's a job that has proven
to be one of the most
difficult jobs I've ever had.
But the most rewarding.
And I wanna keep moms connected
and supported and heard.
Well, giving them a break
when they need it the most.
So when I heard the story of the mom
behind this viral picture,
and I do mean it went everywhere.
I knew that I wanted to get to know her.
And this is our very first moms timeout.
(happy music)
- I'm Jana Coombs.
I'm a mom to four beautiful kiddos ages
nine, seven, five,
and eight months old.
(giggling)
I live in Sharpsburg Georgia.
My husband, Luke, is
an essential employee.
He's went to work throughout
the entire pandemic.
So we've been busy to say the least.
I like live in the kitchen.
Between four kids,
(happy music continues)
living in the kitchen.
Trying to explain
(soft music)
to kids what COVID is
was kind of hard because
they don't understand
the magnitude of the situation.
And for them to not be able to go out
and see their friends
was very challenging.
They didn't understand
(soft music continues)
why school wasn't starting.
The most difficult time
throughout this pandemic
has definitely been
the first day of As Rose
Kindergarten, virtual learning.
And within the first 45 minutes
is when all of this took place.
He just bowed his head down
and his tears were just rolling
down his face and he
had his shirt pulled up
and he just was so overwhelmed.
Not just broke my heart
because for a child to sit there
and cry, it just shatters your world.
Cause as moms, we want
to take that pain away.
We want them to be excited for school.
We want them to learn with enthusiasm.
I was very hesitant to post
this photo on Facebook,
but I knew that I wanted
other moms to see.
And that photo quickly went viral.
We've had thousands of
shares, millions of comments
and it made headline news
all around the world.
So I knew that was really
resonating with a lot of families.
I know that I'm only one voice,
but I hope by sharing my story
that it helps other
mothers not feel alone.
That we're just trying to keep it together
one day at a time for our kids.
(indistinct)
- Bye,
bye.
(crowd applauds)
- Welcome Jana for our very
- [Jana] Hi.
- first moms time out.
(crowd applauds)
- Hi, so excited to be here.
- Oh my gosh.
I am, thank you for coming on our show
because I can imagine
everybody wants to talk
to you about this
and the way that you described
your situation with Ezra,
you know, about how you
want to take the pain away.
As a parent,
- Yeah.
- when they're suffering.
I just really was in awe of
how well you told your story.
And I think that's
- [Jana] Thank you so much.
- [Drew] why it resonated
with so many people.
How are you in Ezra now?
- We're doing good.
Our County allowed face to
face learning to start again.
So he was very excited
and seeing my kids happy,
just makes me happy.
- Okay, so Ezra is back in school, right?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Yes, he is.
- How is that going?
- It's going great.
He is so excited to be back
with his teachers and his friends.
And he just said," Mom,
it feels normal again."
So just having that normalcy happen again,
just puts a smile on my face
because that's all I want
for my kids right now.
- And why do you think if you could guess
why this picture made such
an impact with people?
- I think that it's just
reality for so many,
like you said, it's not just Ezra
or myself going through this.
It's all of our kids, many ages.
It's not just kindergartners.
It's first, second, third,
and middle school and high school.
So we're all in this together.
Just taking it one day at a time.
- I also wanna mention that your husband
is an essential worker and
- He is.
- that's another thing
that's a really important
narrative this year.
How do you manage all of this together?
- So it leaves a little bit of a less time
but he's been really
supportive and gives me
lots of breaks as well.
But with him being gone,
I think just adding
being a teacher in two, three kids
and having an infant has been really hard,
sometimes it's next to impossible (laughs)
(sighs)
- [Drew] I can only imagine.
(upbeat music)